a tens of thousands of people in Hong
Kong are taking part in a New Year's Day
March police have approved the latest
rally and called for its to remain
peaceful demonstrators demands include
greater autonomy from China and an
inquiry into police brutality well the
protests started back in June in
response to a now scrapped extradition
bill divya gopalan is there and she
joins us live
Divya huge numbers of people on the
streets of Hong Kong everything's
looking where you are
that's right hala just purely on optics
it seems like this is going to be one of
the biggest protests so far in those
seven months of protests this is the
first of the year now this January
protest isn't actually an pro-democracy
and annual protest that is held there
usually large numbers but this year el
b-cells surpassed recent years what
we're seeing behind me are people
walking towards the destination this
charts of the March is about a couple of
kilometers behind me they're at a park
but we're also people seeing people walk
towards the park because they want to be
counted in this protest but the
government usually does is just count
people who are leaving the venue rather
than the people who join the March so
they're sending very strong message
saying that they want to make sure that
the government hears their voice and it
starts getting ready for some kind of
dialogue the concessions the people here
on the march are asking for a long way
you said it's more universal suffrage
more democracy China less interference
from China but also in an investigation
into what they're saying is excessive
force used by the police over the past
seven months they're also calling for
police not to get a pay rise that
they're due this year saying that the
police need to be investigated in what
they're calling alleged police brutality
so who's taking part in these protests
well you're seeing people from all walks
of life here young and old families even
young children not the people you
normally see during those spontaneous
protests that have been taking place
almost daily over the past seven months
including last night where we saw some
violent clashes as protesters clashed
with riot police yet again
we're also seeing trade unions this time
we're seeing industries organize
themselves so they can recruit people
people who are want to be part of the
protest but don't want to be punished by
their companies which has been happening
over the past few months so it seems
like there's a much more organized force
we're seeing on the streets today and
along with that we're seeing this their
organizers is saying that 2020 is the
year of resistance once again sending a
message that 2024 Hong Kong looks set to
be another Europe protests and it
certainly will be have had more than six
months of protest night Divya how much
longer do the protesters think they can
sustain this pressure well you know it's
surprising Haleh because when it first
started many people thought that you
know it's it's a flash in the pan or
last through the summer when children
when the students who have been largely
pushing this movement and the young
people go back to school or go back to
their jobs the protest would fizzle but
it hasn't in fact it's it gained
intensity for a while the violence
increase and even with that we saw a
more public support for the protesters
because they saw the government not
listening to what their what they wants
largely ignoring them and they also saw
the police pushing back or pushing down
against the protesters there have been
six thousand arrests since then
thousands of rounds of tear gas fired so
you know it's hard to tell how long they
can sustain it but if we go by the
energy where we're seeing today it looks
like this this will continue until the
government actually opens some kind of
dialogue the chief executive meanwhile
has said that she just recognized it's
been a year for anguish for Hong Kong
it's been a hard year and that she will
try to listen to them humbly whether
that makes any difference or not or
whether they follow through on that
promise you know so far we haven't seen
them make any moves to appease the
protesters so until then it seems like
these protests will continue how hard to
tell how long they can sustain this but
you know the energy we're seeing seems
like it is sustainable okay Divya Gopal
and their life for a saint hong kong
thank you